did you uh let's switch gears did you
put your money on Whitaker or on stuff
that's Alvin you did you did hmm ooh my
favorite nothing crazy
well what is so damn good then find
enough to an active oh yeah really and
you saw that you didn't see a
second-round TKO though I mean knock I
don't know I I know I called it under
four but I thought like said second
round but kind of member second round
two but I thought I said second round
TKO but I don't know yeah that's dumping
just because I just out he's that he's
that he's that [ __ ] good yeah no
one's gonna be in for a long is he on
the same level kickboxing as someone
like Josh Schilling or those guys oh
yeah really yeah his MMA kickboxing is
lightyears ahead of those guys so he's
now gonna fight Paulo Costa hmm
what's your take on that who destroy him
he'll destroy how Paul is not technical
enough I don't think try to wrestle on a
little bit know who did you try not come
out I just don't think he's that's not
the best game to play with
I mean he's long-range so good guys
problems but stop Ben are so good man
he's acting so [ __ ] good see he's
here for here's here to stay for a long
time yeah besides Acosta there's not a
ton maybe dere until if you were to beat
Kelvin you could see that that'd be good
oh you mean cuz they have they have
similar pedigrees King looked it'd be a
fun fight yeah yeah how well he'd have
to fight well Mozilla smaller Darren
till 570 though where is he going on 285
he's going up his next fight through the
against Kelvin Gastelum mmm-hmm
Daron Shaw has his work cut out for him
he's had a race head I know he's yeah
here's the skills young yeah he's not
that young hope I get this [ __ ] together
yeah oh dear until Finn is right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]